Alright. Should we get, should we, yeah, hold on. I'll pull my daughter down.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I am Robert Krulwich. Hi, today just for gigs,
we're going to start in a park.
Yeah, so let me set the scene please.
A couple of days ago we gathered a bunch of Radiolab listeners in McCarren Park
in Brooklyn. You guys are amazing for coming out today. Thank you so much.
This is a random set of listeners. Random celebrities showed up.
Whoever's showed up as a result of a few tweets and Facebook postings got about
70 people in just a little bit more. It's a super cold day.
This park was covered in snow and we had brought everybody there to help us make
some noises that we would use in this segment, like
gasping or
[inaudible]
chanting and you'll, it was amazing. You'll hear them throughout the hour.
But when got people got there,
we hadn't actually explained to them why we wanted them to make these noises.
So just to start things off, I just asked them a couple of questions.
Okay, so a questions at the moment. Take versatile use. Ask,
how do you guys like football?
Uh, how long have you guys hate football?
This is not a shocking revelation. No.
[inaudible] football will disappear in the next 10 years
with these anti football sentiments.
I believe they say more about you and I and our fans. Then again, although I,
in fairness,
I mean there are a lot of people who I would even consider myself a a,
I watched for the ads. Okay? Whether you watch for the ads like you are,
whether you love the game like I happened to you or lows it like some others,
football right now
it's huge. It is through the roof.
97 and a half million views.
Sunday's game was the most watched event in American television history.
Superbowl Sunday had become a national holiday.
It's massive. Massively popular. That's not the same as well.
I get to think it's massively interesting.
Also, here's the way to think about it. Sally Jenkins, author of the book, uh,
that real all Americans, she puts it this way.
Imagine a thousand years from now, maybe 10,000,
maybe a hundred thousand years from now, we're all gone.
All our history has been forgotten.
All the silly trifling games we played in lost to time.
Imagine the future human beings looking back on us. Let's say, you know,
some archeologist goes around digging, they're going to find these really,
really huge stadiums.
That's what they're going to find. Okay. Yeah.
And they're going to understand just like we understand about the Greeks,
what was really important to us.
Okay. So here's the thing, Radiolab listeners, we're going to do an entire hour
on the game of football
in part because it just seems to me that there are a lot of questions in the air
about football right now about what it really is and what that means about us
and what it might or could or can't become. Am I going to like this? Absolutely.
This, in a way,
this whole hour is for the people like you who really don't care about football.
And I am willing to wager that the end, they will care more,
particularly because of this first story which comes from Sally Jenkins who you
just heard. Uh, it comes from her book, the real all Americans. This is a story,
a not about the game as you might think of it now,
but about where it came from.
It didn't come from the people you'd expect. Okay. I'm folding my hands in.
You see here in my lab and I'm going to listen to this. Okay.
You want to get in the three point stance?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
we're ready to begin. And it is a story about the beginning. Well or not quite,
I mean football, football is as old as sort of the Celtic civilizations.
I mean you can trace of primal games of, you know,
Danish invaders kicking skulls around the shores of England.
I mean that's not a football kick exactly.
But of organized football is really a creation of,
of the 1860s and seventies in this country.
It's a post civil war creation comes along, uh,
just really a couple of years after, you know,
the last great conquering armies settle the West.
Basically she says you had these kids whose parents had fought in the civil war
and then some of them had gone west to fight the, a Lakota, the Cheyenne,
the wrap over the Apaches. And now those wars are winding down,
which oddly enough created kind of an issue for young men at the time.
If you're a young student, say back east at a fancy school like Harvard,
how are you going to prove your own toughness? I mean your older brother, your,
your father, he, they may be fought at Gettysburg. Add a little big one.
What the hell have you done?
The American frontier experience was over,
there was this feeling among a lot of intellectuals that um, that um,
American men were losing their masculinity.
They were being feminized in a sense.
So according to historian David Adams,
you just heard those kids were desperate for opportunities to man up.
There was this cult of money
familiness around this time,
David and see a bunch of violent sports take off.
And in particular for our purposes, you see these kids at Harvard and Yale
getting together and
knocking the snot out of each other in this game that's kind of like rugby,
but just more violent.
The game used to be basically brutality.
The origin of football was such a profoundly different game.
Write a check close to a and before him historian Dr. Conrad Crane, you know,
a first down instead of 10 yards was only five yards.
He had three downs to get five yards and basically all the teams did was sort of
slam into each other and try to move the ball incrementally.
It was almost as if every play of the entire game was a goal line stand in the
metaphor people always use when discussing football of course is, is military.
It's the idea of taking land and giving life.
Well the origin of football that was even amplified.
There were formations and strategies and that kind of thing,
but it was pure like right out of Napoleon's military playbook. I mean,
where you, you concentrate your force, you know,
shoulder my shoulder next to your shoulder, nick the, his shoulder.
I think it's a lot like you bunch up all the,
all your man and then pierce the other guy's army. Yeah.
That was the basic idea. So you just end up with piles of guys. Yeah.
And inside those piles there's all kinds of things that go on in those scrums.
I mean there's kicking his bite and there's gouging languaging and crotch
kicking and wow, head wrenching.
And I remember we were talking about Harvard boys doing this.
I have to work to imagine that because I think of Harvard and Yale now and I
think of like, I think, yeah, I don't think of it as big guys.
Well at the time they were the, the,
I mean there are all these wonderful stories about these chops that they would
eat for dinner.
I mean they were drinking milk by the gallon and the Ivys were the great power
of the time physically as well as intellectually.
But then along comes the school,
this tiny little school founded in 1879 in the middle of nowhere that if you're
a football fan or just a fan of American history kinda changed everything where
it was Carlo, Carla was in Pennsylvania. Right. Very close to Gettysburg.
Let's go there. Let's, so, so, so tell me about what is the wind,
does it formed and what was there?
The Carlisle Indian school is formed by a former of,
well actually he was an active military officer at the time named Richard Henry
Pratt, the guy shock of white hair, large nose. Pratt had served gallantly,
quite gallantly in the civil war.
And then he had actually served out West in Oklahoma territory. Uh,
he had fought, uh, American Indians himself.
And it was after winning a lot of those fights, too many of those fights really,
you were talking a 1870s, now that pret had a change of heart and he,
he suddenly became concerned about the very people he had just been fighting.
The fact of the matter is that Indians were in very, very desperate situation.
The bison were almost extinct.
They were being pushed onto reservations and population fallen to two.
It's almost all time low.
Uh,
Pratt, um,
and a lot of other policymakers came to the conclusion that something had to
happen fast or Indians would literally become extinct.
They would in fact become the vanishing race.
And so Pratt, um,
he comes to Washington with an idea.
His idea was to start a boarding schools specifically for American Indian
children. That was kind of a radical experiment.
Children will be taken removed for several years at a time.
They would be stripped of their,
what was called their savage heritage and they would be civilized,
I. E. They would be white. It was, it was forcible assimilation.
A Pratt had a slogan, kill the Indian, save the man.
That's Barbara Landis Carlisle Indian school biographer.
We went up to Carlisle to talk with her and her colleague, Cara Curtis,
and they told us that Pratt basically made that pitch, kill the Indian,
save the man, not just to Congress,
but directly to American Indian families all over the country. I want your son.
Is that, how does that work?
I want your children because white people are going to keep coming and coming.
They want to settle in your lands.
They want to take your lands and you need to learn how to deal with these
people. So we need to teach your children how to speak English.
We need to teach them how to communicate with the white man so that when the
white man comes and tries to get you to sign away the black hills,
you won't fall for it again. And it was a convincing argument.
Well, do you know back in those days or you're talking about survival over here?
Would you mind introducing yourself? Okay. My name is Joe American horse.
I'm 79 years old and I'm a grandson of chief American heart.
Joe Lives near the Pine Ridge reservation in South Dakota. He's Lakota.
And he told us the story about his grandfather,
who was a famous Lakota chief in the 1890s.
His grandpa led a delegation of American Indians to Washington.
Well, he went to Washington DC and he, he was down here,
but he's a lot of people downer
just as his grandpa had this moment where he was just stunned by how many white
people there were. His phrase was there like an,
and pretty soon they're going to come to the, our area.
So he had the idea of uh, trying to send his kids to school so they can,
uh, inner mingle or you know, intercept or whatever.
Basically Joe says his grandpa just had this realization,
we can't, we can't go back. We've got to go forward.
And it seemed to him Carlisle was the way forward.
So where are we going now? This is our photo archive. As kids are admitted,
here's how it would work.
They would come in and they'd immediately have their picture taken on arrival.
Then they'd be given an extreme makeover, which would also be photographed.
Okay. Really?
Wow. This is Tom Tour Lino. Wow. This is, this is Tom Carlino as you,
as he comes in,
Barbara showed us a picture of a Navajo kid looking maybe 18 years old,
does 1882 this is when he arrived. So he's got kind of dark skin,
high cheekbones in long earrings.
He's wearing elaborate necklace.
It looks like it might be made of bone and he's wrapped in a blanket and then,
and then the, here he is in a suit with clean cut hair. And the second picture,
his hair is very short, not long, no blanket swearing,
a three piece suit sitting there with a cro,
Fox and a spread collar and a part of here. Wow. It's like in a snapshot.
You have Tom Indian, Tom White Man,
[inaudible] and Sophie Jr American horse,
said his family saw that transformation firsthand and Sophie was there in
Carlisle for five years. And when she came back and she looks like a wind woman,
you know, she had a real tiny waist and a vomit and everything and uh,
she can't speak Lakota.
She forgot [inaudible] it. Just think about this for a second.
Just think about this. And we spoke with one guy, a professor, Eric Anderson,
who teaches at Haskell. He's also a part Pottawatomie. Just imagine the parents,
he says the first time they see their kids,
parents are seeing their students marched around in essentially the uniforms of
what had not very long before for many of the tribes been the uniform or the
enemy at the very least.
I think that would be startling.
Ninny case. According to Sally Jenkins,
after the kids were re cropped and redressed,
Brett would run them through a bunch of drills and Carlisle was a,
a little military academy and the Indian kids were so unhealthy at first.
They had been put on an unfamiliar Diet.
They had been sleeping indoors for the first time in their lives and a lot of
them were getting sick. I mean,
we know that in the 39 year history of the school,
at least 200 kids died of disease or poor health or even homesickness.
And so Pratt was constantly trying to get the kids outside and [inaudible] at a
certain point he,
he had hired some teachers and Sally thinks that one of those hires,
probably one of the first dormitory masters,
this guy who had formally taught at an Ivy League school,
he showed the Carlisle Indian kids. Yeah.
This game that the kids at Harvard were playing,
maybe he thought it would toughen them up. Who knows? But suddenly
they are playing football. Now keep in mind, this is, you know,
at a point pocket 1882 where football's barely a thing.
Not so many schools had teams.
There wasn't such a thing as a head coach back then.
They were volunteer coaches who tended to be students or students with the
Carlisle kids self organize level. The fields start to play.
They even start to scrimmage some kids across town. And at one of those games,
according to Barbara,
Stacy Matlock who was a Pawnee student at Carlisle later became a plenty chief.
He broke his leg
playing football and press it. That's it. No more football
because in his mind he was trying to civilize these kids and football was doing
the opposite.
Uh,
short time later, since David Adams,
approximately three dozen Carlisle boys came in to Pretz office and they said,
we want to play football.
Do we know what they said? Exactly?
We do. We don't have, we don't have the exact words,
but Pratt says at one point, he says,
while they stood around my desk and I'm quoting him while they stood around my
desk, their black eyes intensely watching me, um, he says,
the orator gave practically all the arguments in favor of our contending and
outside football and ended up requesting the removal of the embargo.
According to his memoir,
Pratt was sort of bowled over by the eloquence and passion of the appeal.
So we said, okay, you can play if you do these two things. One, he says,
never slung people who are looking on, we'll say there, that's the Indian of it.
Just see them. They are savages and you can't get it out. Okay.
And the other one was you have to beat the best teams in America.
And at that early point in American football, far and away,
the most powerful team was Yale, which brings us to October 24th, 1896.
It's, it's a raw fall day in New York. They played in New York.
Yes. At, uh, the old polo grounds, barely.
There was about 4,000 people in the stands,
including a handful of newspaper men,
New York newspaper men knew Jimmy was a big story. How did they publicize it?
What did they say? Well, the newspapers became incredibly intrigued
on one side or the undergraduate. She has an old and great university.
[inaudible].
Hey represents basically the perfection of modern athletics or intellectually
the culture and refinement of the best modern American life. On the other side,
we have originally the real showing on the forest and playing the red skin of
history. Story of war developed over me,
or as the case may be by education,
and if you read the newspaper stories,
they're written as they're written in this kind of blood curdling shot through
with Indian cliches, you know the red skin, they here come the red skins. Right,
right. According to David Adams, in one paper, it was a reference to yodeling.
The writer said that then the fans were yodeling in that Indian fashion. I mean,
try to put yourself in the shoes of a New Yorker. In the early 1880s,
your contact with an American Indian was in a wild west show. It was theater.
Uh,
and here comes a football game and all of these American Indian kids run onto
the field.
And there's literally an instance in one of the first games with [inaudible].
Someone in the audience says, well,
they look just like our boys because of course that's what Brad wanted.
Now one thing that was immediately clear to everyone in attendance when they saw
the Carlisle players was that they were physically outmatched.
Do you ever have, your weight is
164 a shack 20 pounds by two to one man.
And going in is that there'll be an absolute smear job, or at the very least,
the odds are heavily against him. But
[inaudible]
three minutes into the game, in the midst of a big up
[inaudible],
a Yalie fumbles the ball. It comes squirting out.
Carlisle guy picks it up. Yep. And runs the entire length of the field.
63 yards scores the touchdown.
Now nobody had scored on Yale in seven games. They were furious.
So what they do is they use their bulk,
slow,
push the pile down the field twice to take leave.
Yeah.
And with three minutes left, yeah.
Lists up 12 to six Carlisle has the ball Carlisle running back charges the pile
in, gets clobbered, falls backwards.
And just as he's about to hit the earth,
he laterals the ball to a teammate who grabs it, runs around the scrum.
The entire length of the field of score.
[inaudible]
Carlisle scores a touchdown that would have tied the game,
what
it's called back by a referee who was a Yale man.
Why the call was that the referee claim that a whistle had blown the play dead.
And what was the crowd's reaction? Uh, well they were, they were furious. Yes.
Bullying and hooting. Everyone knew it was a terrible miscarriage of justice.
And some of the Carlisle players said, oh, we're gonna Walk Outta here.
We are leaving this game. But according to David at the last moment,
Pri runs down from the stands, comes onto the field. Just wait a second.
Wait a second. Wait. Don't forget. [inaudible]
rule number one, be a gentleman.
Pratt did not want this game to end because of their tempers,
even though they'd been wronged by, uh, by that call.
So the Carlisle boys finished the game and when they walk off the field
[inaudible],
they get a standing ovation. Carlyle wins,
incredible respect and renown in the aftermath of the game. In fact,
one of the newspaper men after another Carlisle Yale game or something
similar happened,
wrote something to the effect of a Carlisle could beat 11 year old men,
but they couldn't beat 11 Yale men and a Yale referee.
Yes.
After the Yale game of 1896, Pratt is committed.
Pratt believes that it's the greatest thing that can happen to his school.
It is an instant way to do what he's been struggling to do for 15 years at the
Carlisle school,
which is to prove the value of these American Indian kids against their white
peers, to prove the value or to quit civilize them. Well, both to civilize them,
but also to prove that given education and equal opportunity,
they were the equal of there. Hm. That's interesting. Their white peers.
I mean he was for all of his forcible assimilation methods, which were,
you know, to remain extremely cruel and destructive.
He truly believed in the concept of, of racial equality.
The complicatedness of Pratt and of the whole Carlisle idea kept smacking us in
the face as we were putting the show together.
I mean on the one hand they were clearly students who felt that Carlisle was
prison. Is that Barbara Landis,
when she took us on a tour of the grounds of the former Carlisle Indian school,
she said that kids would even set fire to the buildings. It's, yeah,
some did burn down, which is kinda typical on Indian campuses.
A lot of fires and burning buildings. Why? Um,
it's a form of resistance on the other head.
No, you see,
when we started looking around for original archival recordings of some of the
earliest Carlisle players, pretty much the only recording we could find
has this tape. We would like for it to be as much of your making is possible,
was this oral history with a guy named
your name. Your full name is Andrew [inaudible].
Albert x and dine.
All right.
The interview was done in the early seventies. When he was 88.
He entered the school
just before 1899. You were 50 years old.
Can't really play you too much of this cause the audio quality is really bad.
But in the interview, Pratt comes
r h Prek, Pra, d, G
and X. And Diane talks about them with a great deal of affection and gratitude.
We call him the diff father of ending education.
We call him the father of Indian education. Yeah.
Oh, he was a wonderful man.
So he's a tough figure. Pratt, and he's got very mixed legacy. I mean,
I like to say Pratt was his country.
Whenever you think of him, he was his country. So, okay, so 1896,
he gets the bug, like he sees p football's a good PR. Yes.
What happens next? Well, he, he hires, uh, he begins looking around for coaches,
full time coaches to come in and coach the team. Uh, and he winds up, um,
with a Cornell Grad, uh, named pop Warner,
Glenn, Pop Warner. Now,
pop Warner was an interesting guy because this pops right here just to give you
a visual. Whew. Look at him.
And Carrie showed us pictures. It looks Kinda like a Mike Ditka.
If Mike did go ahead. Einstein's hair up pops a little bit of a,
of an outlier case. He's got these Texas roots, he's a bit of a rogue,
can be kind of vulgar party a little bit.
He liked to gamble really.
And that is exactly what he does in spectacular fashion when he gets to Carlisle
because pop Warner looks at at his squad and he realizes that,
sure they're fast, they got heart,
but they're underweight and they're small wasted wall. You know,
while they might occasionally force a tie with it with a Yale if they, you know,
have killed themselves, uh, physically,
they weren't going to beat the Ivy Leagues on any kind of consistent basis
without, without doing something different. And, um,
there was a very fine line between innovation and cheating.
And Pop Warner starts exploiting that line. Absolutely. Uh,
as hard as he can. And he comes up with, uh, the trick play,
for example, 1903 pop Warner devices, the hidden ball trick. But what is that?
The hidden ball trick is I'm the quarterback takes the ball and actually behind
this huge pile of men tucks it under another guy sweater while the big pile of
men is struggling in the mud in the center of the field,
not knowing quite where the football is,
but believing it's somewhere in the middle of the pile.
Here's this kid who squirts around the end with the football hidden under his
Jersey and he's 30 yards down field before anybody realizes it.
And how does he keep the ball from falling out of his jersey?
You'll have the flu.
I think they actually sewed the Jersey so that the ball would stay in there
without falling out. So they made a cheating pocket and made a cheating pocket.
Was that legal? But they got it. Did they get their religion? Was it legal?
You ask pop Warner would have said there was nothing in the rule book against
it. Another thing he does, which actually works brilliantly is uh,
he sows footballs onto the front of their jerseys,
which are really bulky sweaters at the time.
He sows leather football shaped patches onto the front of their jerseys in order
to try to disguise who's got the ball really,
I guess Harvard and the Harvard coach goes insane.
[inaudible] send me pregnant. This is the kind of thing, I mean,
but Harvard did not take this line down.
Harvard retaliates by painting the football's the same color as their jersey.
It's my room everywhere. So when they held the ball against their chest,
basically, well, you can't see it. I mean they all broke the rules.
American football is essentially a rule breaking experience as opposed to
British football, which didn't have referees,
at least initially a British football ran on the honor system.
But with American football, the rest were there practically from the beginning.
And she says it was largely a response to the brutality of the game,
but also to the kind of rule bending that you saw from pop Warner in the
Carlisle Indians. Every time pop Warner came up with an innovation,
the next year there was a rule against it.
So immediately the Ivy League would get together and pass a rule and say, okay,
no more of that.
And that's how the rule book really burdens in an American football.
And it's thanks to pop Warner's slights of hand in pop Warner's greatest slight
of hand and maybe the Carlisle Indians most soaring moment.
And I mean that literally happened at a moment when the game almost uh,
disappeared. That's coming up.
[inaudible]
start, isn't it?
Hey, yes, this is David. Adam, this is Conrad Crane.
Can I get an email message asking me to read credit text Radiolab is supported
in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of
science and technology in the modern world. More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org Radiolab is produced by Debbie N YZ and distributed
by NPR. Okay. There it is. Oh, we can use that. They care.
And this message.
Hey, I'm Jen Abu Moron. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
And getting back to our story on the Carlisle Indian school and the birth of the
monitory game of football. One of the most important moments in this story,
a happens at a time when football was right on the edge of disappearing.
[inaudible]
talking about 1905 this was the most violent year in football to this point.
19 people died on the football team.
One nine one death is alon 19 that's crazy. Yeah.
Cause what would happen is that Carlisle would try and do these things to sort
of open up the game.
The ivies would consistently respond by making the game more about brute force,
more about violence.
So you had all these tests and suddenly all the major programs were spooked.
You know, Columbia polls, their PR or their football team.
Harvard even thinks about doing that.
And this is kind of odd into the fray steps.
The president of the United States of America, Teddy Roosevelt, in order to,
cause he was a fan. According to Conrad Crane, he liked football. He liked the,
the manly aspects of it, the tough aspects of it. But nobody like people dying.
And then there was his kid, his, his son was playing and,
and getting beat up pretty badly as well. Uh, broke his nose, slid his eyebrow,
and one game he got knocked out cold. So after the violence of oh five,
the president calls the president of all these colleges and so on and to
Washington, and according to David Adams,
he basically tells them that the rules had to be rewritten.
It had to become a little bit more safe at least, or it would be banned.
And out of that, we see a couple of rule changes. First, uh,
the schools decide in order to loosen up the pile, so to speak,
they're gonna Tinker with the down yardage ratio. You know,
instead of going from three downs to gain five yards,
it becomes three downs to gain 10 yards,
three downs to get tenure to four downs to get 10 yards.
Four would come a couple of years later. Oh. But the second rule change,
which is maybe the most important for our stories for the first time they
legalize the ability to move the ball through the free floating air.
It's surrounds us all. Okay, so where do we go watch the next day?
So if I could, if I could place you in a moment,
unless there's a moment before this, you'd like to hit a,
I believe November 23rd, 1907 yes. Yeah, big moment.
Okay. Can you set the scene? Well, the, the scene
from the standpoint of broader American history, things have gone airborne.
You mean Wilbur and Orville, right. I'm talking about not just them,
but I'm talking about hot air balloons.
[inaudible]
there are aeronautical experiments happening really all over the world.
In France, everyone is experimenting with flying machines.
Things are going up in the air,
but not so fast with football because when the rural committee had made that
rule about Ford passing,
they had also hedged a little bit saying if you throw a forward pass and you
receiver doesn't catch it, you are penalized 15 yards,
which back in the day was a monster amount. So nobody threw the ball.
It was too risky. But story goes, as soon as that rule got past,
pop Warner goes back to his garage. It's always a garage quest with a ball.
And he starts experimenting. Any sort of thing. All right. Okay.
What would be the most efficient way to toss this thing?
And people have to understand that the footballs and those days are not the
footballs we have today with the Nice, yeah,
of whatever that old oblate spheroid or whatever they call it with a nice points
and things. These are rugby balls, sort of imagine a deflated basketball.
They're thicker in the middle. They're not as well shaped.
They're really tough to get your hand on to throw. Right,
and in 1906 there's a tiny bit of tape in Albert x and [inaudible] oral history
where he talks about this in 1906 he says, pop called all the players together.
You tells them
hi rollers.
If you wouldn't have to learn to decide in a Volvo.
He says, I think you're going to have to learn to spiral. The ball
does as far as the ball,
because if you throw the ball in a spiral,
it gets 10 times less air drag than if you throw it end over end.
Plus it's easier to catch. Yeah.
They start experimenting with it a little bit in the,
in 1906 but they come out in 1907 as a throwing off fence,
which gets us to that game.
November 23rd,
1907 Carlisle plays the University of Chicago last game of the season.
We're in Chicago and the Chicago team is arguably the best in the nation,
the best.
I don't think it's even arguable what Carlisle is good at this point though.
Yeah. But Chicago is like stag field
and there are 27,000 people in the stance. Well, what happened was,
uh,
the Chicago players had decided to try to defeat Carlisle's innovative folds
passing by just knocking the crap out of their receivers every time they came
off the line of scrimmage. And so Carlisle's greatest receiver,
Albert x and Diane,
our guy had been stymied the entire game because the minute the ball was
snapped,
Chicago players would hit him and try to throw him down or knock him out of
bounds.
So pop Warner said to x and Diane,
here's what we're going to do next time they hit you out of bounds.
Sneak around the bench and get back on the field by some accounts.
This was x and Diane's idea, but whoever thought of it on the next
Albert x died as expected. Ends up out of bounds, but it keeps running.
He runs around the back of the bench, runs around the spectators,
maybe around the band and comes back on the field right at that moment
Hauser the quarterback of Carlisle
lets loose a vicious spiral. Can I have you read recently? Sure. Okay, hold on.
This is Sally's description of that moment from her book,
the real all Americans. For a moment it was a frozen scene in a stage drama.
The ball hung in in
the air, a tantalizing possibility could x and dine reach it.
Would he catch it or drop it? Defenders wheeled and stared down.
Field spectators watching from the stands found that breath had died in their
collective throat.
[inaudible]
the spiraling ball seemed to defy physics. What made it stay up?
When would it come down in that long moment,
27,000 spectators mashed together on benches and crammed on platforms may have
felt their loyalty to the home team evaporate in the grip of a powerful new
emotion. They may have noticed something they never had before,
that a ball traveling through space traces a profoundly elegant path.
They may have realized something else that it was beautiful.
Uh,
the ball struck it's human target x and don caught the pass all alone and
trotted over the Chicago gold line.
[inaudible] exploded in sound and motion.
The rest was just anticlimax. The final score was 18 to four for Carla
[inaudible],
but the very next year,
the Ivy League passes a rule that you can't leave the field and then come back
onto that. Yes. That's where that rule comes from.
They get a say that that description of the ball in the air is,
is timeless in a way.
That's exactly why football is still beautiful at times. That's, that's,
that's when Carlisle in 1907 is when American football becomes the sport that
you watch today. Exactly. Our story.
Oh Wow. This is the field field. This is the field. Can we get out?
Yeah.
After we'd spent an entire day looking at pictures of, you know,
Albert x and dine and Pratt and pop Warner and Douglas Lone Wolf and Tom Merlino
and all these Carlisle players.
Barbara and Cara took us to the field where they practiced.
And so this is the Carlisle Indian school football field covered in snow
like 10 degrees out here. Really,
really bright sun coming off the snow and it's just empty.
And we just kind of walked around and tried to imagine all this stuff we just
seen in photos. It was a little bit like walking among ghosts. Yeah,
that's the sound of the flag blowing in the background.
I remember standing on that field and I'm having this thought that I couldn't
quite articulate, but later, um, Eric Anderson,
that professor from Haskell is a member of the Pottawatomie nation.
He sort of put his finger on it and he essentially said that like,
there's a lot of room on a football field.
Okay.
I mean there's room for anger and war and violence,
but there's also room for pride. And a kind of coming together.
That's not a Pratt coming together where one side gets erased but it is a coming
together.
Yeah, I mean there is a middle ground. Clearly it's more than a game.
The stakes are higher than that. You know,
will we as Indian people be accepted on our own terms and
also in our ability to meet you halfway.
Will we be accepted through this as the vehicle?
It's clearly more than a game.
[inaudible]
a lot of people to thank for this episode. We had original music, uh,
made for us for that episode from Morgan O'kane.
You can hear him right here playing the Banjo. That's
Morgan O k a n e music.com. Check him out.
Also we had original music from Austin musician,
shaky graves and the Albert and Diane tape that we'd played is from the research
division of the Oklahoma historical society.
Thanks also to the Cumberland County historical society in the U S Army Heritage
and education center where you can go and see tons of photos from both archives
or you can come to us on our website,
radiolab.org we have a ton of old archival football picks,
a ton of those before and after pictures from the amazing, really amazing.
And we also have a link to Sally Jenkins Book,
which is highly recommend the real all-americans that's on our site,
radiolab.org thanks also to Reggie Kathy and to Scott Graham to Noah Robbins to
Michael churness to Matt Della Pina.
Cole wimpy to Jr McCarthy to Nick Cup would beat Jay calling and Michelle
Campbell at Heber and special thanks. Very special.
Thanks to our amazing volunteer cheer squad that came out and weathered the
Brooklyn cold to scream and Holler and bring this story to life.
And speaking of that very special thanks to Brenna Farrell who found the story
and produced it with us and a production support from Damiano Marchetti. Wow,
that's a lot of people to have that. But we will have,
we will have more to listen to.
And more people to bank in the second half of our program. Yeah.
We're going to take a distinctly modern view on football coming up.